you're the worst [__] piece of [__]
I've ever seen with the littlest [__]
dick I've ever seen you can't please
anyone with this [__] horrible small
dick of it yeah yeah yeah like whoa
interest Chicago I know you are cute all
right make a light boys hi yeah are you
from virgin where'd you grow up
born and raised in beautiful Los Angeles
you're a girl I'm an LA Queen as they
call it
what part of Dana well part of LA well
full circle
like South Central Los Angeles okay
Crenshaw district but I moved around LA
Pasadena Long Beach you know the valley
North Hollywood no home and then I moved
back to South Central which is where I
live now and tell me about your family
yet both your parents yes I do both of
my parents are alive and well and yeah
my dad lives in like by San Diego and my
mom is like kind of Pasadena area tell
me about your childhood yet both parents
when you were young yeah you're gonna
know you are getting to the dirt yeah my
childhood was real sketchy so Marty like
triggered so how was my childhood
growing up it was kind of crazy my
parents they they did not end well so my
dad kicked my mom to the curb for
another woman and whatever and I was
like witness to that [__] and then after
that like I moved in with my
grandparents and then my mom got her own
place and she's had her own place but
yeah things are kind of crazy we moved
around a little bit but my mom really
handle business
go ahead black strong black a woman mama
you know I love you
my mom's the best she held it down with
me and my sister and yeah my dad was
freaking off do whatever and not a bad
guy but yeah just never around so any
crazy abuse or anything unusual yeah
truth be told at a very young age I
don't know maybe I was like eight or so
could be but yeah I had an incidence
with I don't know an older friend of the
family guy made me suck his dick I like
a very young age probably it was like
ten eight probably so maybe truth be
told so yeah that was kind of bad and I
don't know I was just actually very
sexual at a very young age or introduced
to sexual things at a very young age so
yeah that did happen in that I think
affected you know my eye started sucking
dick at a very young age though call it
a blessing call it a curse whatever but
yeah so that was kind of strange and
then yeah I was just from there I was
just like started a little like
listening to like 976 numbers like after
that I had another friend of the family
who like called these numbers and I was
like listening to them and then I
started calling them and I was like back
when you had like a telephone bill and
that's when we lived with my
grandparents and my grandparents my
grandfather like found the little phone
bill with all these 800 numbers his bill
was like $1000 and then it was like I
guess he called the number and it was
like can't this yeah you want to [__]
[__] this cut it was like so explicit it
was so bad so I got look like aah
and so that was you know fine so yeah I
don't know I've just always been yeah
that's just what it was that's just what
is so at some point you got home yeah I
frickin left home as soon as I could
move out I freaking
the [__] out just to be on my own so I
like 18 years old I moved out have my
own place I was still pretty innocent at
that time to be honest with you I just
know that I once have my own place and
move out actually I did have a boyfriend
so that was part of the reason he like
needed a place you know where he was
like you know gamed me into like yeah
let's get our own place
yeah that's true that did happen I
probably went away at my mom's NSYNC
somewhere buddy I need a place like got
kicked out of my house let's go move
away and living together so yeah
so I did do that so what did you start
working as a prostitute oh [__]
as a prostitute hmm well officially like
when I first turned my first trick you
know like when I made it official you
know I'm saying not figurative
prostitution literal yeah I literally
had a boyfriend and then I tried being
and then he I don't know he was into the
seedy life the seedy like you know he
went to like bloody ranches and like
[__] like that before and then you know
so whatever so I was like trying to
that's when I that's when I first got
introduced to like the game like as far
as you know he was like oh he wasn't so
called a pimp but I see how he
definitely picked me like he definitely
turned me out he definitely got me to be
more like daddy let me bring the money
home to you let me make that money let
me bring that hold you down a Bo bottle
I got into all of that because of his
ass inadvertently it was crazy how it
happened but it did I was a working at
it went from going working at a [__]
insurance company selling people down
medical dental dam long-term short-term
disability down [__] damn near Rock
dam near robbing [__] to get as
much money as I can [__] gay from they
asses
how did that happen it was crazy but it
happened well yeah I first started off
it was the easy slope I know he loves
strippers so I was just so eager to
please this [__] I was just like
I could do any [__] thing any
of these [__] out here can do I can
strip it [__] I can [__] Act I
can [__] and get money I can cook you
know you just feel like I need to have
something improving some [__] like that
so he made me do it like I was like I
know I got you you know in like it as a
woman they always say you're supposed to
be submissive or whatever right which I
know I'm like a alpha female but
something about when you find a do that
makes you want to like submit like I
respect you like I wanna I don't know
it's something primal I really don't
know but [__] that [__] clicked
when they say [__] choose a
[__] [__] then I guess I chose
a [__] leg I choose you I want
to work for you and be on your team and
make it happen and make your money and
[__] scheme [__] vos and all
that [__] I don't know
basically your pimp he was basically I
feel suited to it so I started off I was
like I'm gonna be a [__] stripper I
have the [__] tits and asked to pull
it some [__] tips but what I didn't
have is a this gift to the other pole or
the [__] patients I said they're in
sweat in [__] all this time Bishop
for like 20 bucks I tried it for a day a
half a day and even finish my shift and
I [__] quit
then I answer some damn ad I won't name
what the ass [__] place was but I
answered one make a [__] $100,000
[__] make a [__] thousand dollars a
night or more I'm like yes that's what I
want to make a beautiful looking for a
beautiful hot girls likes to have fun
yes that is me me mate hey babe set your
own hours [__] knows I don't like to
wake up early yes let me look into this
so I [__] answer to damn add I went
down there I was like [__] I can do
whatever they throw at me
I never [__] worked a day in my life
a half a day as a damn stripper and an
insurance [__] salesman and then I
walk into this escort [__] company
they I was like okay what the [__] am I
doing there like entertain bikini girls
and you just are companionship or
whatever this type of [__] they were
telling me I was supposed to do I was
like okay I'm entertaining I'm a great
companion I'm [__] charming as [__]
once so of course
so yes I am very well qualified for this
so I [__] gave it a try and it was
like what am i doing exactly then it was
my first day on the job what am i
[__] doing where should get the
[__] show fee which is the thus set
afford a [__] amount that you [__]
get out the door first
you know agree to put him out whatever
it is for whatever time about my eyes so
yeah I went to my first little thingy
and I was like oh [__] this [__] is
getting real and I was like I write I
look like a little innocent little girl
not to draw too much attention to myself
so yeah but then I met this guy and then
I was like yeah but I'm here to have a
good time with you sir
top some fun it's like ya know so yeah
so let's just take care of the business
and then yeah we'll just get comfortable
and have some fun right yeah things like
gave me my money time about got it
then the [__] I have to get the
[__] money out I have a driver
outside and [__] and the guy is like
don't [__] go anywhere with the money
and then and then the [__] got real like
oh what they didn't train me for this
dude what oh I'm going outside and
taking this money because my messenger
takes up my money and tastes
I don't know you have to [__]
[__] so all your [__] toes then
luckily I was able to but it was real I
said what because they said take it out
you know take the money out you have a
guy that shanks you there take
money out so seeking money out and then
guys like we're going I had so many
people will rip me off you're not going
anywhere with money it's like Oh relax
get baking let's go so anyways dude I
don't even know how to tell you that the
guy my driver was like what the [__] he
had his pepper spray ready it was like
dude it just was like dude what is going
on I got the money off I was like dude
he's just gonna go away he's gonna go
[__] get a cup of coffee and then
we're gonna go have some fun you have to
[__] relax Shh
take control so I did that's when I was
like I'm a [__] Jia this [__] okay
handled my driver get the [__] out of
here
get the [__] around the corner I'll
handle this [__] it's like do baby okay
he's going by go get out here
it's like took him with the money then I
go inside and then yeah so that guy had
to calm his ass down pour some drinks
let him do whatever he likes to do who
to relax even though that cuz also coke
is very good because also they get very
high and horny but their dick doesn't
forcing work which can be good or bad
but anyways that's another story that is
so so true right hey I wouldn't open all
right we're good you don't know these
things but I'm just saying if you have
that it could be good good thing or a
bad thing but anyway see just relax you
know I just let you know whatever I
dance real sexy and then I was doing
like little sensual massages to get him
to laid the [__] down get down and then
if he had more money then I would try to
get that and of course
Shh to really have some fun that's what
started yeah and I was just then I was
just really I was in there I was like
it's like yeah I'm gonna try to get
whatever he hasn't is whatever I saw a
couple more dollars in your wallet sir I
want all of it and then depending on
what he had then he would have fun and
we would see how much fun we went and
that was like my first time and out and
that was literally I was like I can't
believe I [__] did that and so he had
a little more money and we didn't
definitely have not did not have sex
because I was technically in love with
someone else but we did I mean I
definitely made sure that he came or
whatever you always wanted to go as soon
as possible skating that's just only
being yeah a business-minded
yeah let's just get this [__] person
to come but you have to give him a good
time you have to balance it I mean has
to be both but anyway so that was my
first [__] time I think he gave me an
extra 200 bucks so he was like paid
whatever the amount was four or five
hundred bucks that first time and then
it was just so exciting he had fun then
after that I was all relaxed oh you're
so great and I'm like okay cool
nice to see you and then yeah it was it
was nice I liked watching people like
come for me I realized this line of work
is not meant for every girl I know it's
really some girls seem to take to it and
have like a fish to water and they have
the ability to endure a lot of things
that it requires right yeah you know
there's just good eatin up exactly I can
totally see how you can totally get
eaten up and yeah I luckily didn't get
eaten all the way in the [__] up because
I think I was already used to that like
sexual energy towards me like from such
a young age that I was just able to like
manipulate it and then you know after I
was already sucking dicks for like I
mean I'm a really good dick sucker oh
jokes aside
really good so I don't know then I just
liked it I don't know I morphed it I
just took to it really immediately but
then yeah then once I got that first
little hit
I made that quick money I mean I got in
there and they're like less than an hour
which is always what they shoot for and
you paying for an hour and hopefully you
come in 30 minutes that's just what the
dude let's just say too much sorry
ladies boiler but yes how it goes
ladies how they're working about
thinking about it but yeah then I
started to like it then I started you
know like if you have a real sexy ass
client yeah I'm saying and it's just
them perfect like I would have [__]
you anyway for Fraser but I think you
are throwing money I mean trust me it
does turn me on even more and so you
really like like you know [__] down
some really random stranger that you
just think it's really sexy in you like
damn we have some good I remember the
first guy they made me squirt I didn't
even okay to be honest he wasn't very
attractive but he's really eat ate [__]
super super good he had a whole I think
wife or somebody in another room he was
like my roommate right I don't know
maybe that was that's when we squirt I'm
just going here with your wife next door
no this is true though well yeah he was
like my roommate and then I was like
your wife it was like 3:00 4:00 in the
morning and he's saying yeah and then I
was like [__] it but he ate some good
[__] and then I don't know what
happened but I just squirt that time but
now I was like oh gosh and he gave me
extra wedding hey I like this job so
yeah it's been like a heart it's like a
once you get that feeling then I got
like you know into it then I was like
you know [__] my other job then when I
quit my nine-to-five that's what I knew
I was deep into it I was taking day
shifts night shifts was like I know I
could we can make make way more
so yeah it was a good time your career
started there and there's different oh
yeah
there's different ways of making money
yes that's true and have you
experimented with I mean you're a
high-end now well yeah that's shoe
luckily I didn't start you know like I
feel like the level the low I wouldn't
say the lowest level to talk down that
mean money way I like I mean if you're
on the street I was never like on the
street that's a whole nother vibe like
actually the street vibe you know like
standing out there you know having car
dates and stuff like that I know a lot
of girls who had that so yeah I didn't I
started at the escort level so I know
that's a whole nother life wouldn't know
long yeah that's a whole damn another
life with the car dates and standing
outside dangers yes so much more
dangerous and so that's like whew that's
really about their life and then I when
I first got locked up I saw this
beautiful as a girl in jail and I was
like she was on you know like it was on
the track right here in the valley I
won't say what Street but you know Sam
it was here in the valley if it was in
the valley on a particular Street that
had notorious for prostitutes but she
was [__] gorgeous smells like you're
on the [__] corner and then I was
thinking how much money she can make in
like escorting like you can make us so
much more because she was popping dates
for like 60 80 I mean those the rates
are I think a lot way lower for the
girls I was like oh [__] and then that's
when I started being a madam that's when
I slid into mad at me yeah then I was
like why am i doing all this legwork
you're the girls of your own I did which
is almost like a being a pimp exactly so
I did do that I was just like why am i
doing all this legwork you know doing
you know like taking all that thing so
I'm just a I'm just you know like
recruit a couple of girls and then yeah
I'm gonna work them but in since I said
it is it is a lot to deal with all these
[__] personalities and then these
[__] want to fall in love with some
broke-ass and I get like we have money
and I was like I won't say like who but
I was definitely into like Hollywood I
mean like I wouldn't say I was like the
hottie flight the black Hollywood Heidi
Fleiss but I wouldn't say I wouldn't say
I wasn't but I wasn't the [__]
black mother [__] Hollywood Heidi
Fleiss that's a lot of issues I might
work but anyways yeah so I had I was
doing that very successfully until yeah
it all crumbled down would just I got
pinched because this one Czechoslovakian
chick who was gorgeous and happened to
love black [__] up her ass so she was a
[__] gold mine and she actually fell
in love with some guy that worked at a
freaking drug store chain manager
anyways yeah so then I got pinched
because of her because yeah
yeah she pinched the police yes
we got freakin pinched because her dumb
ass goes outside of the box outside of
our formula once you go outside the
formula you already knew I was like this
is our powder formula she she heard me
before she made me formula I was just go
to senayan hotel freaking go to a lobby
you know like try to get around to drink
see who's biting whatever and then me
guys and then if they stay at the hotel
go through the room blah blah blah bleh
which is I mean that's something but
it's my I mean
it's it's it's something that does
happen
so we she was trying to get me up on
that scheme she's like let's go to this
high in hotel to be nameless I think I'm
still banned from going in there oh yeah
let's go there whatever sour for
freaking tricks right let's just call it
what it is so I was like whatever this
is not my gig I don't like being a
sitting duck I don't like just [__]
[__] lounging around for whatever
like going a while back and I need to -
she was like lounging around see who buy
whatever but she stayed at some
apartment I need rent money whatever
desperation is the worst recipe for
disaster
so she was desperate to make this money
whatever so I was like whatever I'll
come here and buy some drinks I see what
she was on so yeah we have some drinks
with some dudes
long story short she's telling some dude
like yeah he says he has all there's
some money in his hotel room right
whatever so we go up there I was like
this seems sketch and then so yeah she
told me that no she told him I was like
nah this is [__] sketch so long story
short she goes into the bathroom with
him talks whatever and I'm usually the
mouthpiece cuz that's what exactly the
operation she was the brains the beauty
in the buns and I was the mouthpiece I
don't know a [__] side deal she was
doing in there but obviously she was
doing some dumb [__] then the guy told
her he had his [__] that she comes
out of the [__] bathroom being the
guy [__] says I have the money in my
car while we're in a high-end hotel and
they have a [__] safe in there like
dude though ice has a safe in their
[__] room and then puts the [__]
three-to-five $10,000 in a [__] car
down in the [__] car lot I was like
dude let's go she's like no he's getting
the money he could see my knee no he's
not let's bounce she won her [__]
money I was like dude but somehow I was
going out of there damn rushed in on
this damn so he was definitely enough so
how much time do you do I took my other
sketchy situations that being there over
the weekend she got bailed out of course
she was like I'm going to lose my green
card which I think she did but yeah she
got [__] bail down and let me there
to rot in jail
I didn't write it was like a week but I
think it was I probably could have gone
out because it got thrown out apparently
because a guy barely showed her his dick
I don't know they bought it two drinks
it was just a real hairy investigation
and they're like [__] whatever they
just put it a wash it was pimping and
pandering that was my charge so oh
really
hey got my strike a lot of females have
that right I know right I call it a
badge of honor how much I mean you've
done this in different ways how much
money have you saved money well that's
what I'm saying
as anybody would tell you I don't know
why would you get that fast money you
feel like it's gonna last forever and
you spin it quickly somehow so I'm truth
be told I mean I could have done some
better financial rising but yeah I was
like quick money in if I'm making a
thousand a night cash and then you have
habits and then I mean I also get a nice
apartment so rent in a LA so that was
already a lot and then I don't know what
happens then slowly but surely them then
when I got out that's some saying that's
why you get addicted to the money the
fast money why you can't even really get
out you're like dude I need to make this
[__] amount I'm used to making this
amount I need to make this and then once
you're like dude I have to keep making
this and this like the game changed and
everything like that is it said that I
was in the era when a people are like
doing la weeklies barely a couple of
like maybe other websites but barely any
craigslist once craigslist got into it
it was like then it was like low-end so
it was like slowly but surely now
everything now I'm like virtual now I'm
like a webcam girl that's the way were
the [__] future so now I do it
virtually that's what I'm saying I went
that but I still do like as I said I
haven't dipped all the way out cuz I'd
still do like sensual massages I'm still
like why not
I have that skill of your high-end
clientele I do
so why I'm not gonna let that go it is
so I mean I do have as I said these
long-term relationships that I've built
up first for you know like a nice solid
few that I have built up because I give
like a very great experience I'm like
you know I was like the psychology of it
I want you know like to feel like a real
connection I mean like whatever so it's
a [__] business transaction but I
just I mean I can't like see your soul
and like heal you and [__] like that but
it makes you much better what you do it
kids a drug I do I have one and that's I
have a daughter so and she's at the age
where she's in her coming to that
womanly age and I was like man I you
know I'm saying but she's very clean-cut
so that's the good news
when you raise the opposite well yeah I
mean sometimes I have been literally had
to rely on her dad and my family members
I'm not gonna lie because I got locked
up more than a couple of times well her
dad you know literally wanted him with
her more than a couple times he said I
was incompetent akai had as some drug
issues and not saying I just you know so
I haven't been the best mom I'm not
gonna lie can't even take really any
credit for how awesome my daughter is to
be honest just you know what you do for
the way she might know she might know
but she knew that's why but she made a
comment about Craigslist one time and it
really made me laugh I was like oh [__]
so um she does now yeah but I think she
already knew she saw a couple of met a
couple random somehow or the other one
of my transactions which I never that's
like you never do that but these were
like longer people so it was like I see
us going to the ATM Allah there mommy
happy them
it's crazy but Stu is this line of work
ever get in the way of your love life
your personal oh that's a great question
this this I think definitely has
affected this lifestyle has affected my
love life because it takes me and me to
get in sentimentality of where I'm
always trying to like you know hustle
somebody in a way like you're you know
like putting on my Ida can like they
call it the girl now they have Stern's
like girlfriend experience you know
where to where I'm pretty much like your
girlfriend okay there's some other
reason weather subtitle funky chi you
know obligations and [__] like that so
but I'm just like yeah I'm like I'm
gonna love you care for you support you
and give you that whole like song and
dance and then I'm just like am I always
doing that of our relationships and not
getting paid for it
hmm it was like it was miss Li like
startling so then I was like dude can I
ever but I know I believe in love and I
said the person I love they didn't have
any money or anything so you know I'm
saying I was like that was true love but
was that really very stupid because we
could have fight paedo use that all that
money on myself instead of giving it to
him but I just like the ride it's just
like when you're gambling or something
it's like you'd like the [__] or even
buying a lotto scratcher you just like
you just like the [__] excitement of
it all even at the end you're like I'm
probably gonna lose but I like enjoy the
the [__] ride wasn't worth it I love
enjoying life s I'm saying [__] it
whatever money comes and goes I had
[__] so much fun some crazy [__] to
thank God there did anything then in
tragically but I was living on the edge
when she living on the edge of life like
an outlaw somebody's crazy story when I
got shot at when when I [__] one of
the tricks as I said then okay as I said
I start off the game I was innocent
[__] then I started really like
thinking I had
then to do like you know I'm saying I'm
like oh right he paid me this and this
has to happen and then like [__] were
telling me they were like no you don't
have to do [__] like just like rob these
[__] I was like I don't have to do
anything I was never that I was like I'm
gonna give him something that doesn't
seem fair he was telling me about how
he's cashing out his child's goats
tuition baby f8000 well there goes oh
yeah well it'll be worth it you have a
great story no so one time I was in this
place and then and then I was like I'm
just trying to get him out of here and
the plus like I only had like a hundred
fifty bucks so then at that point a
hundred fifty to me was pretty much I
don't even want to spend five [__]
minutes in there right that's just how
my mentality I got so I was really just
[__] just trying to just really get
it in and out of there I was just trying
to just [__] cash and - as they
called it right so I was trying to do it
he was like I have 150 already expected
sped up my little approach or whatever
and I was like let's get to the bottom
line how much this [__] guy has to
spend to have fun tonight then I
realized the only didn't only he was
bringing out like rolls of quarters and
[__] like that I was like you know what
this is this is gonna be very quick this
is not gonna in the way you probably
wanted to because 150 plus a roll of
quarters is nothing to me so yeah then I
was like okay whatever then I was like
yeah you get comfortable whatever take a
shower whatever you say they're always
trying to [__] jet and just then I
was like all right getting scouring
getting my clothes off he must have felt
something like I'm in there too long I
don't know what happened it was just
like I was made getting ready it's like
what are you doing you're leaving
already and I was like oh I'm just gonna
get something out of my car you know I
was trying to like [__] jumbled and
he was like what what he's like no
you're trying to leave I was like no I
was like I'm gonna get something and
then out this one I was like oh [__] and
then I was like no I'll be right back
well I have like my bra and and I had
this [__] jean skirt that was my
[__] moneymaker just choo-choo-choo
throw that [__] on and then I [__]
jammed out of there without my [__]
brows like
kid like driver was stuff you like what
was like go go go and then I don't know
what then he was like oh [__] so I jump
in the car the guy was like oh crap
then [__] and you guys turn the car
the guy runs back and I was like okay go
freaking the number one rule of [__]
getaway driving is you don't park head
into like a [__] coldest a queue park
going out so that way you don't have to
like turn the [__] around and [__] go
head in and make you just [__] be
ready to [__] that's just another
little hint of the game if you're like I
need a getaway driver don't [__]
don't face towards any dead ends
don't [__] head towards any [__]
cold effects so we're [__] spinning
around this colour psych and I was like
oh [__] we have to go back and from the
house what's wrong with you of course
the guys like in the [__] Street like
no give me my money back like oh god and
he was like peddle to the middle leg
room I was like oh my god I was dipped
down the car was like oh no cuz someone
had already thrown a brick at us I was
like oh I don't want any shattered glass
in my face so then I hear a pure dream
was like oh shoot the frickin guys shot
at see went inside and got his gun and
freaking shot at us looks like oh [__]
then we had a journalist she's like oh
my drivers like oh [__] then we spun
around their way freaking got a whole
flat tire it was a mess
I was like oh [__] damn that was crazy
at that point I was like oh [__] how got
rules [__] we call her freaking agency
oh my god the guy shot us they're like
oh you guys alright yeah we're good we
have a flat tire so we're like oh my god
they're not gonna find us no we didn't
get very far at the time it was like
booop mood like freaking gave out
immediately but they're like if you guys
can call it your way we use like I'm
gonna change to have a flood so my guy
forget change it and then they were
trying to make us a work further like
okay we have another call for you guys
at the freakin whatever I'm like [__]
you think I'm a [__] we'll keep
working up I got shut greedy bastards
no I'm going home that was crazy but I
didn't quit I was like that's it I quit
it's too much did I quit I do not quit
that was crazy
what was the best time you're like well
I was the same when I was with that
freaking guy and I was literally out
there it just was so exciting to me I
was like had my little nine-to-five job
was my regular check right and I was
like man and then I saw his little
whatever boo Lake likes you know
Hollywood lifestyle he wasn't even a
high end like entertainer APIs but I was
like you just get to pay you know like
he didn't have a nine-to-five I was
already getting up to work and then when
I found this as I said when I found this
company and they were giving me out for
to me every like every like call they or
Mike hall was like really seeing
sunlight I'm like this is like really
nice like nice homes I'm just like you
know looking at family pictures and just
like you know this guy asked me to wear
his wife's clothes one time it was so
weird but it was like so cool like like
and it was at nighttime like I just
something about like it was night and
was just out there you know like between
night shift was 9:00 p.m. to [__]
5:00 a.m. that's some crazy [__] between
those times where I would go see people
and it was just like really like I loved
I'm like a sight you know like
sociologists I just every different
house is like a different story I was
like I should write down all these
[__] different scenarios it was like
so many different scenarios different
guys different scenarios why they called
you know you should always ask like
how'd you call and then they would say
like oh yeah I broke up with my
girlfriend or like my wife's out of town
or like whatever the case was they were
just [__] doing blow all night
whatever you know went to a liquor store
once I mean it was just like hilarious
but it was so I got like so addicted to
it then you come off with a lot of money
then you're like let's go have breakfast
eggs and then you [__] like that was
a [__] coal mine and you do it again
because the money it was just to do
quick money was what was the worst time
of your life well when I had to like
literally I started getting in trouble
with the law too many times and I just
literally ended up having to go to Joe
for like four months but it was on it
like a domestic violence and I literally
missed my daughter's freaking graduation
high school graduation cuz I was in jail
and that was really I think like the
worst day ever
how do you think this life has changed
you it's definitely I mean I know what I
mean I just made it just makes me look
at people a whole different way like
before I would see a certain person I
would think they're a certain way or
have think I would have some kind of
idea of how what kind of person they
were and then when I was doing that you
know meeting all these people in like
I'm like oh my god just seeing what
they're into like some some guy will be
into like you know like ridicule just
like humiliation and then you know
you're just the worst
I tell it told him it was the worst
you're the worst [__] piece of [__]
I've ever seen with the littlest [__]
dick I've ever seen you can't please
anyone with this [__] horrible small
dick agree yeah yeah yeah like whoa
interesting or mini it's just like I
really wouldn't but it's at the same
time I really like to know about people
I really am addicted said I want to be a
therapist or something I just really
like knowing people like all they're
like weird creepy like so I just think
this is so weird but you get a lot of
customers that are into kinky strange
and usually
fetishes a lot of ones this one guy was
like I'm gonna write you a check for
$3,000 extra if you can use just only
your thighs and squeeze it around my
head and if you can make me pass out
I'll give you extra to $3,000 I was like
what are you sure yeah I suppose already
hard as I could a couple some sake okay
he's like I know you can do it faith
eyes they're strong enough to make me
say I'm up for the challenge but what
would you what would you say how would
you feel if your daughter somehow
decided to follow oh that's what whoo
thank God as I said thank God that um
she didn't have to go that route I think
it's just not but yeah if she did I
would I mean hate to say it but I would
be opening I mean like literally I would
have I'll be very OPA belay be very open
with her I mean I I don't know what's
still love her and support her but it
would hurt my heart like to know that
she had to do that like as I said
there's nothing that you want you know
as I said it's a strange thing like it's
nothing that you would say like I mean
I'm built for it as they say I'm built
for that life but it's nothing that you
want to spur sace definitely see your
daughter all that weird should I have to
put up with I would never want her to
put up with any of that [__] or have to
even be in a position to be like that
you know in other hand I know I can do
it I know I see the fun in them whatever
I can deal with it but I wouldn't you
know like I wouldn't ever want that for
her you know so thank God as I said she
didn't see me as like a like a crazy ass
example and then she just followed my
route like all right my mom's out here
who knows all times of the night and
whatever you know seeing you know
different guys and she could have easily
just like used her body like but I think
the very big key is that her dad is like
in her life
I think that like really is what the
difference possibly was because my I
have you know like I am like yeah call
me daddy yeah I don't have one I mean
that none that I've been on that I
[__] claim and so yeah easily fell
not saying that that's an excuse but I
definitely you know like I was like yeah
I need someone to [__] raise me daddy
and provide for me and my guide me and
[__] love me and [__] like that so
that was definitely a part of it for me
all right Nico thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you
resume you're so cool yes very much
that's what's up thank you
you